All right.
We've got some very sick and needy audience
questions today, some of which are coming
right at me and I love it.
Let's get to the first one.
David, aren't you a hypocrite for criticizing
our financial system and then making money
from it, investing in stocks and bonds?
And I'm sure paying as little in taxes as
you are legally allowed to.
No, no, I am not a hypocrite.
Listen.
This has been explored in so many different
ways.
Why doesn't Bernie just pay more taxes and
send checks to the IRS?
Why does Noam Chomsky, one of the greatest
critics of some of the inequalities in our
economic system, have a trust or some other
mechanism?
I believe it is.
So he can transfer his mutual funds, which
include ownership of oil companies to his
kids while paying as little tax as possible
or whatever the case may be.
We've really got to desegregate this stuff
and and think through in a bit of more critical
way what we're really asking here.
Let's take first let's take some examples
first.
If you believe taxes should be higher, why
don't you just send in more money?
That's not policy.
OK.
The idea that just the people who believe
taxes should be higher, sending in more money
is how you resolve a problem with government
tax revenue or fairness or whatever the case
may be is a joke.
And in fact, if everybody isn't do it doing
it, there is really no reason why one person
would do it, because it wouldn't make a difference.
And this is why a lot of these things need
to be done collectively.
The groups that like to say just leave this
stuff to charity.
We don't need social safety nets.
We can just leave it to charity.
Well, maybe, but that's not policy.
Maybe people are more generous versus less
generous one year to the next.
You can't fix problems in society predictably
with that policy.
So, you know, here in Massachusetts, you have
I think there's this option.
You have to pay a higher income tax rate.
I think the income tax rate here is five point
five percent and you can pay like five point
eight if you want.
I always put no.
And in fact, I actually don't even think the
state income tax needs to be higher.
I think where we need more in higher tax brackets
are federally.
But that's a completely different question.
Along the same lines, I am a person that exists
in society.
I believe there are many problems with our
economic system.
But does that mean that what I need to do
is put my money under a mattress where its
purchasing power is diminished by inflation
every single year?
What would that serve?
Other than to unnecessarily impoverish myself
by keeping money under a mattress?
I believe, for example, that capital gains
should be taxed at or as ordinary income.
Does that mean that when I file my taxes and
I only pay 15 percent on capital gains, I'm
going to say, hey, you know what?
Let me just send the IRS more money.
No, that's not policy.
There is no hypocrisy.
As long as you are not, you know, advocating
for nonviolence and being a violent person.
Right.
I mean, that we can find these types of hypocrisies
that would be different.
But recognizing that we exist in a certain
financial system, we are people.
We have a desire for well-being and whatever
else.
And we are going to play by the rules that
are there while explaining that at a societal
level, we would be better off if the rules
were changed is not hypocritical.
Adding And the example of Noam Chomsky having
a trust to I forget the exact response he
had when he was called out on this.
Some reporters said, you know, you talk about
inheritance taxes and this that, but you invest
in mutual funds that hold pieces of oil companies
and also have a trust to give money to your
kids.
Chomsky's reaction was what I should I should
be a popper or I don't remember exactly what
the response was.
But the point is, these are not societal questions
that the individual is making.
And, of course, you should live your values.
And if you individually say for me, I would
rather lose my money than have a retirement
possibility that includes owning mutual funds,
then do it, then go ahead and do it.
But to say anybody who thinks oil companies
are bad but owns mutual funds is somehow a
bad person.
Come on, guys, who even has time to go around
making those arguments.
Let's just work on improving the systems we
have in fixing the problems that we have.
Rather than trying to find these gotcha questions
of people who, you know, have been made have
made very clear what their values are and
how they believe society should
be organized.